everybody is Charlie this is gonna be a
big Rick and Morty season four update
dan harmon recently posted a tweet that
offered some context for why everybody
had gone their separate ways and they
weren't working on season four right now
his tweet shifts a lot of this on to
Adult Swim but it provides some more
context for statements that they made
last year when they were getting ready
to premiere season three and spent a
little bit of time joking about what was
going on with season four so I cut down
that clip of them talking about it watch
this then we'll decode their drunken
statements because I think they're
having the same problem with Rick and
Morty at the network the Cartoon Network
had with Adventure Time when it blew up
real big earlier he was like I love you
guys but the show's a hundred percent
canceled there's too many numbers can't
crunch them anymore
so that we should see how many episodes
in the next season season three or four
[Music]
not to it not to say that there's a four
there's a PR person freaking out right
now and two two agents yeah our
contracts are up so yeah let's get real
honest yeah so season 4 will be really
good season 4 I meant season 3 well
season 3 is like CGP keep leaking season
4 and we don't know about season 4
season might not happen it depends on
how much of the Hot Topic Slipper money
we pretending the show's not turning a
profit where after you give me my
slipper money I just want a pair of
slippers over here a pair of slippers at
least my feet are cold
no they mail us like one pair of
slippers
but we're gonna I mean tonight what we
plan to do is solve a lot of problems
like productively Justin and I we're
gonna figure out how to make season four
faster more efficient we're gonna open
the hood on that creative process and
like you know help you help we're gonna
do it help ourselves like generate Rick
and wordy so much faster that season
four can premiere up to two hours after
season three yeah if there's a season
four right which there might be we might
die in a horrible accident this all of
this has been scripted and rehearsed
every word including what I'm saying
right now man I miss Justin so much this
is so awesome
so taking that in context now with Dan
Harmon's statements the network hasn't
officially renewed the show
it sounds like they want to the basic
problem is money in monetization so a
lot of you if you are big adventure time
fans or if you remember when that series
blew up a long time ago one of the big
problems that Cartoon Network had with
it is that they're mostly programming
for younger viewers and they just
weren't prepared for how popular
Adventure Time was going to be and it
was so weird they didn't know quite how
to market it so they weren't able to
monetize it as fully as they probably
could have so they wound up missing out
on a lot of money that they could have
made on the series and that's really
what networks care about like they want
to make good content but their
corporations that want to make money so
one of the big problems with Rick and
Morty isn't that people like it that's a
great problem to have they're like oh
great we'll keep making Rick and Morty
as long as people want to have it but
from the network's standpoint if they
don't know how to monetize that
correctly or if they don't have a plan
in place if it blows up even bigger then
they wind up missing on a lot of dollars
so I think what their problem right now
is is that they're just trying to figure
that out
deploy the Galactic militia and declare
martial law yes sir
what should I pay them with their
payment is the honor they'll feel to
serve there wait who's paying me to yell
at this guy I can answer that for money
so when Dan and Justins say that their
contracts are up for renewal obviously
they probably want to negotiate for a
bigger cut of the profits so like when
Dan Harmon is joking about this mythical
Slipper money that they're not getting
that's really what they're
can you bout like they make a lot of
money on the merchandising off of Rick
and Morty but it doesn't make a lot of
money the same way the traditional
network TV makes money off of ads like
they sell ads that air on Adult Swim but
most people that watch Rick and Morty
actually stream it off their website
streaming ad rates are a fraction of
broadcast rates so they're just making a
fraction of the money that they would
normally make if this were a network
show airing on a major network so it
don't swim executives are probably
pulling their hair out trying to figure
out how to better monetize this but
don't swim being part of Cartoon Network
everybody probably talks about series
that they just missed the boat on so
they don't want to miss the boat on Rick
and Morty like if it's gonna continue to
blow up and do really well they want to
make as much money as possible on it
listen I want to see you to do things
for this bag of money okay man so
because Adult Swim hasn't formally
renewed Rick and Morty for season four
it means that they're not sending dan
and Justin any of their budgeted money
to produce it meaning that dan and
Justin can't pay the production staff so
when Rick and Morty season three was
over they had to release their staff
after a certain period of time like
usually a network television when you
get close to the end of a season shows
we'll find out whether they're canceled
or renewed so they can release their
staff and those people can go find work
on other television shows or they'll
renew them so they can start work on the
next season but during that normal time
period when Adult Swim would have
renewed Rick and Morty season four they
probably saw it blowing up and they had
this contract renewal but dan and Justin
so there was probably a big money issue
that prolonged that then it blew up
really big in Adult Swim is like okay we
need to plan on how to make more money
off of this so that by the time they
figure this out and get things going it
would be like a late 2019 release like
Ryan Ridley one of the other producers
was talking about on a recent podcast
I've already posted a video about that
so I'll link it at the end of this but
it's basically him just saying that no
there's no work being done on season
four I don't expect it to be released
till late 2019 which does sort of sync
up with mr. poopy butthole white Santa
Claus beard statements
[Music]
a couple of grandkids and all that kind
of stuff see you I do wonder how late
they actually cut that mr. poopy
butthole scene because when Dan Harmon's
talking about trying to get season four
out even faster it sounds like he didn't
plan on this really huge hiatus and he
does sound genuinely sad that they're
not able to get it out faster so with a
moment it just sounds like it's gonna be
Comic Con before we get any like real
meaningful update I still expect them to
do a comic-con panel will they'll be
like okay you know this is what we're
working on at the moment even if they're
not officially working on season four
I'm sure Justin and Dan are thinking of
ideas so they felt free enough they
could tell you about some of the
concepts that they're gonna be working
on for season four but by the time we
get to comic-con we'll know a little bit
more about that they're doing a festival
that they're using Rick and Morty to
sell that's happening in October so
that'll be another big event but usually
with a lot of animation it just takes so
long you don't get a lot of frequent
updates if creators don't spend a lot of
time talking about it but let me know in
the comments what do you actually think
from Dan Harmon's statements and what
they said last year what's actually
going on behind the scenes
I don't think that they're actually
fighting with the network or anything
like that I think that both parties just
want to find the best way to monetize it
so that it's easier financially for them
to continue making Rick and Morty
because a lot of these Adult Swim
television shows don't make a lot of
money which is why you only see them do
ten episodes of season but no worries
I'll keep doing Rick and Morty videos as
we learn new stuff and they'll keep
dropping new promos so they'll still be
stuff happening this year but leave all
your bonus video requests in the
comments below and be sure to subscribe
to get everything
there is an adult animation Deadpool
series that's dropping later this year
that might help fill that void the only
thing I've seen about that recently is
that a couple of news websites were
quoting that it was meant to premiere in
May so I'm assuming after the Deadpool
movie drops but when we get some footage
or something for that I'll start doing
more videos about it but click here for
that video Ryan Ridley talking about
season four and click here for that new
music video thank you so much for
watching everybody stay awesome I'll see
you guys tonight
[Music]
[Applause]